a 5.5 magnitude earthquake is among
hundreds of new quakes that continue to
rock the summit of Hawaii's Kilauea
volcano they are raising concern about
another large explosion the intensifying
lava flow has now cut off escape routes
for some residents in a seaside
community who ignore those evacuation
orders Carter Evans is in Pahoa Hawaii
Carter good morning good morning
scientists say the lava coming from this
fountain behind me is the hottest
they've seen in this month-long eruption
and it's moving fast to up to a third of
a mile every hour so for some residents
who did not get out before the lava
moved in the only way out now is to be
rescued it's what emergency officials
have been warning about for days
lava blasting from Kilauea 'he's most
explosive fissure has reached a major
highway intersection civil defense says
about a dozen people stayed behind
anyway in Kappa ho 3 were evacuated by
helicopter on Sunday including this
woman the areas without power cell
reception land lines or water it seems
like people are refusing it some people
wanted to come out we do know if one
confirmed says nope I want to stay they
have enough food and they say they'll be
able to last meanwhile geologists say
the main crater at Kilauea summit has
been expanding as more than 500
earthquake shook the area over a 24 hour
period lava is now covering more than
seven and a half square miles almost six
times as big as New York Central Park
nearly 90 homes have been destroyed
since the volcano started to erupt last
month including this one captured on
video by a vacationing sheriff's deputy
and what was your concern when you saw
the smoke coming out of that house there
may be animals or people inside the
house he kicked in the door make sure
the burning house was empty and then no
one inside for nightly no sir we were
escorted into this area by the National
Guard but authorities are now cracking
down on people who might ignore those
roadblocks to try and get a closer look
they've now issued more than a dozen
citations for loitering in a disaster
zone John Carter Evans in Hawaii Thanks